(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're asking the questions that you ask us
and then we're answering
them because anything goes.
Yeah, we've opened up the floodgates and--
- The questions just rolled right in.
Anything, anything at all
we're going to answer.
- Well we're gonna, the
ones that we picked.
- We're answering, ask us
anything, we'll answer some.
- But the way we pick
these things is very loose,
it's like--
- So loose.
- You're like oh I picked
some, I picked some,
and then we don't
discuss it ahead of time.
I don't know, I don't even
know my answers honestly.
- [Rhett] Yeah yeah yeah.
- I'm kinda like well maybe
something will come to me
for a lot of these.
- But before we do that,
we will let you know
that we're both about to head out on--
- You givin' 'em a warning?
- Spring breaks.
- I'm excited.
At the end of this recording session,
I'm on vacation.
- Oh, you gettin' a little
bit of a early start.
- That's right.
- You didn't, we didn't
consult on this, however,
you are going international
so you have travel,
two travel days.
I just flipped you the bird.
I didn't it's just a peace sign backwards.
- Are you comin' in, you
comin' in to work tomorrow?
- I'm comin' in hot.
- You comin' into work tomorrow?
- I'm not coming in, well I don't know.
- We didn't consult this,
I need you to come in
if I'm not gonna be here.
- I will be working tomorrow if that's--
- Oh I'll be working, I'll
be thinking about things.
- If that's your question,
just whether or not I'm here,
but you know what.
- You know what, don't work.
- No those day when you're--
- Don't work.
- When you're not here
and I feel like I got this
big old office to
myself, it's pretty nice.
I play all the music that
I want as loud as I want.
I fart openly.
- Nothing--
- Lots of things happen
in there when you're not present.
- You haven't said anything
that you don't do anyway.
(Rhett laughs)
We had a meeting right before this--
- That is true.
- Right before this
recording session, we had a
meeting which was proceeded
by us working at our desks independently
for about two hours, and
they come in to the meeting
and then Jacob was like,
it smells funny in here.
- That wasn't farts.
- You know the first thing I thought.
Well we been fartin' in here.
- Well we've been playing
a game of fart tennis.
That does--
- Our desk space--
- That does happen.
- We face back to back
and I don't know,
yeah we just have a fartversation.
(laughs)
The fart that you ripped yesterday,
it sounded like you were
squooshing something.
- (chuckles) It's that chair, man.
It's the acoustic quality
of that chair that I sit in.
It's almost a musical
instrument the way it propels it
out into the middle of the room.
I think it's designed,
I think that is a design
to shoot your farts out,
the sound of your farts out
into the middle of the room.
- Fart shoot and share.
(Rhett laughs)
And so it'll be like an hour of--
- Farticello.
- You play the music you wanna play.
- Fartihorn.
- Rhett plays this--
- Fartinet, fartinet.
- Rhett plays this,
I don't know it's like
concentration music.
- No no no no no.
- It's got some beats in it.
- No it's lofi 24/7, which
if you just Google lofi 24/7,
there's a few YouTube channels
and this is a Mythical Beast
suggestion back when I--
- Is this a rec?
- This was a rec to me
from the Mythical Beasts.
I've talked about it on
the show before I think
'cause I was like, what's
some good writin' music
because I don't like lyrics
in my music when I'm writing
'cause I start just writing the lyrics.
- Speaking of recommendations,
something I've been meaning
to do but haven't done
for many episodes now is say that hey,
if you listen to the
end of an Ear Biscuit,
we are now doing a recommendation.
- Oh you already know that
though 'cause you're not
the kinds of people that stop
listening before the end.
- So listen to the end and
we're alternating episodes
throwing out a recommendation,
it's a Recs in Effect,
but anyway--
- We're heading out.
- I'm still on the fart story.
- Okay.
- You're playing the
music which it's not like
you don't play what you
wanna play with me there,
you play the music.
- Lofi 24/7, yeah.
- And then we're like--
- It's streams.
- It's kinda quiet.
- Yeah.
- Actually yesterday
there wasn't any music
because all of a sudden
it was just butt music
from you and I just, we
hadn't talked for an hour
and we're just sittin'
there working on stuff.
- You gotta mix things up sometimes.
- Just kinda, we started laughing.
It was very--
- Farts are funny.
- Third grade again.
- We've established that,
we've established that.
Farts are funny and if you don't think so,
something's wrong with you.
- My abdomen is cramping hard
and I might have to add
some music to the mix.
I'm in pain right now.
- But it might be negative pressure,
it might not be positive pressure.
- Anyway so when Jacob
came in and he was like,
it smells like something's
rotting in here.
- And then Josh said it smells
like cruciferous vegetables.
He was right because there
was cabbage inside the dish
that you had sealed up.
- And I'd put in the trash
can so it wasn't our farts
and I was glad that we didn't say,
well we've been fartin' it
up for the past two hours.
- Yeah.
- It's my office.
- Anyway,
we are heading out.
I'm doing another ski trip,
you're doing another Londony trip.
- And by Londony trip, I'm going to--
- Going to London, you're
not just going to London,
North Carolina, there probably isn't one.
- Yeah for Lily's 16th
birthday we're taking her
wherever she wanted to go.
We had this grand idea that
now we're gonna have to do
for the other children.
I don't know, if the bottom falls out.
Yeah, or YouTube shuts
down and our entire,
our entire financial ecosystem crumbles
and then I'll be asking my
16 year old son to house me.
- Oh that's quite a turn around.
- Yeah.
Hopefully it doesn't happen.
- You lookin' forward to it?
- The financial crumble of my--
(Rhett sputters)
Yeah so she wanted to go to London.
We're gonna do the Harry Potter stuff.
I'm sure I'll give you a
full rundown on the back end
but having had our
complete London rundown,
my expectations are primed and I know,
I know how I'm gonna approach it.
- Dinner every night at Slug and Lettuce.
- The food aspect of
it and stuff like that.
Yeah I'm very excited,
I think it's gonna be
a very special, it's designed to be
a special memory forming
occasion for us with just Lily,
with the boys not being there.
- Lots of mental pictures.
And lots of actual pictures.
- Yeah man.
No injuries, no snow, no mountains, no...
Be safe, man.
- But I heard tell that your wife is,
she's a little anxious
because these planes have been
falling out of the sky all over the world
and she's gotta now get in
one and go across the ocean.
- Well we're not on that plane
and that plane's been grounded--
- That plane's been grounded but planes--
- We're not on that plane.
- But planes.
- She has a borderline phobia.
- Right and it's like
and this is in the news
and she's taking that in.
- She's had a difficult week.
- What's your plan?
- Massage?
Take a massage tool.
- Hand holding.
I guess try not to sleep.
- Poetry?
- I'm trying not to
sleep until she sleeps.
- That's not gonna happen.
- That's gonna be difficult
because that mouth is gonna
flop open, I'm gonna be gone.
- She's not gonna sleep and
you're gonna sleep immediately.
Like literally, I was thinking
about this on our last trip.
This is why I always snap pictures of you,
regardless of how long
the flight is, is that,
every single time we get on
the plane and then they start
the beverage service or if
there's a meal involved.
- Yeah.
- You sleep through that part.
'Cause typically that's
like, we've reached 10,000,
whatever the feet is, 10,000 feet.
And now the wifi is working
and we're kinda leveling out
and they're starting to
bring the beverages out,
you're gone and so last
time we were flying,
I woke you up 'cause I was
like this can't happen again.
Now one time you laid down
and put the sleep mask on
and slept right through the
thing and then you wake up
and you're like, is
there dinner? (chuckles)
It was like seven hours into the flight.
And they were like, uh, well, not anymore.
- Something about gettin'
in the air makes me sleepy.
- So you gotta take a Red Bull.
You gotta do a Red Bull
before you get on the plane
if you don't wanna fall asleep.
I do wanna fall asleep but I'm gonna try
to stay awake for Christy.
I mean she's got, she's
been given some meditation,
guided meditations that she can go through
for like some
positive-oriented, some like,
well they're all positive-oriented.
- Some very negative.
- Some focused on like--
- The sound of screaming
people. (chuckles)
- Planes crashing,
careening out of the sky.
- This is what could
be happening right now.
But it's not.
- Actual audio from--
- I wonder if that would work.
- From failed water landings.
(chuckles)
- Certain people might be into that.
- I'm sure there are.
- 'Cause sometimes I
tell my wife, I'm like,
when she's upset with me
I'm like you know, I mean,
you know what I could be doing right now,
and then I make up a crazy
scenario that's a lot worse
than what I am doing.
- Oh yeah.
- And she's like, this
reasoning doesn't work.
- Yeah that's called
deflecting into the abyss.
Usually you deflect to
something that's also concrete.
- I could be in prison right now.
- Okay.
All right.
- But I'm not.
It's like that's not effective.
- I could be a murderer.
- Right.
- I'm not that insensitive.
- Yeah, yeah.
I could be living a double life.
(Link sputters)
- I know that's funny but I also feel like
maybe you said that to her.
(Rhett laughs)
- No, I didn't say that.
- 'Cause it is kinda funny
but you know, you're like, perspective.
- Yeah sometimes you gotta, yeah.
We could be crashing right now, we're not.
If everything goes sideways
you say that to your wife.
- Here's a simple one to start with.
- Why don't we take a small break
and then answer a question?
- I'm gonna ask the question
and it'll be like a--
- Teaser.
- Got it.
- SarahA142266095.
- Whoa.
- Asks--
- What's the strangest
thing you've ever found
the other person doing when
you walked into the room?
- Uh-oh.
- #EarBiscuits.
- You'll get that answer
and more in a second.
But first you can get
my shirt and Link's hat,
part of our storywear collection.
- The Post-Apawcalypse wear.
- The Post-Apawcalypse.
- Apawcalypse,
where dogs take over.
You got this smiling
with human-esque teeth--
- Well he--
- Spiky dog.
- Chompers, is that his name?
Happy Chompers.
- Happy Chompers,
he's so happy.
I love this hat because something about
the materials with which
it's made, it's like,
it's very pleasing, it's very light.
I like the materials.
- Very pleasing materials.
- And it's got a captain's--
- Rope.
- Captain's rope.
- And it's just, it props up there.
- It props up there,
lots of great features.
I have a shirt that features Instagruff.
Again this is a dog.
A hume-dog, or as I said the
first time I read the script,
for the voiceover, hum-dog. (chuckles)
But it's actually hume-dog
and Instagruff is his name.
Get it, he's an Instagram dog
and he got that many licks--
- What you think, Jade?
- Instead of likes.
Get it?
- What do you think of the collection?
Jade is, all of the proceeds go to us
and then because we love our
dogs so much, they benefit.
- That's right.
- So if you want our dogs to
continue to eat and be healthy
and get their shots and vet visits,
you need to buy this merch.
- Right, yeah yeah, we
will stop giving the dogs
their regular scheduled
recommended veterinarian things
if you do not buy these shirts. (chuckles)
They'll get heart worms is
what we're saying, okay?
You don't want our dogs
to have heart worms,
buy these shirts.
- Oh goodness.
- I heard that heart worms
don't really happen anymore.
Your dog Tucker died of heart worms.
- It definitely happened to him.
- And--
- I guess because
of the medication and stuff,
that is squarely our fault.
- But our vet--
- Felt horrible about that.
- Our vet said something about how
you don't have to really
worry about those anymore.
You can still take it
but it's not really--
- Really?
- Yeah.
Okay.
- I give her the medicine.
- Strangest thing I've
seen you doing walking in--
- Yeah so we're answering
your questions now.
Here it is, we're getting into it.
We've made it through the ads.
- The thing that this makes me think about
is the fact that we have our secret loft,
our not so secret loft.
Especially if you're a member
of the Mythical Society,
you've seen that loft in
the Mythical addresses.
But both of us independently sometimes
might get here early
and might use the loft
for meditative purposes.
- Mm-hmm.
- There's a meditation cushion up there.
And I've walked in and it's like,
I see your car when I
get here, vice versa,
same thing's true, you walk in.
Lights are on, you know
somebody's in the office
and you kinda like settle
down into your desk
and then I hear...
(deeply inhales)
- A little nostril flappage.
- A little breathing.
Now I at least say when
you walk in, "I'm here."
(chuckles)
- I'm here.
- I'm here, I'm meditating.
- I'm meditating.
- It's a little weird to walk
in on somebody meditating
but you can't see 'em.
- Especially--
- You just hear 'em breathe.
- Especially 'cause we do it nude.
- Hmm, hmm, I wasn't gonna say that.
- I've never meditated nude.
- You should try it.
- Weirdest thing I've
seen you do when I walk in
on you is when we're traveling or like,
and then I get up in the morning
and you're down on the
floor in your underwear like
doing some sort of contortion.
I was like dude, you sleep
on the floor last night?
I was like, it's like you fell off,
you fell out of a skyscraper
and splattered on the ground.
- I'm practicing my moves.
- I'm like good gosh,
what happened, man?
And then I realized you're stretching.
- Oh gosh.
You know what and the funny thing is--
- The stretches you do are weird.
- Well they're doctor and
physical therapist prescribed.
I'll tell you one thing,
they have gotten--
- Just in your boxers, it's
just, I don't wanna see that.
- You don't have to watch.
- Well I didn't watch, I just saw.
- Some people would pay to watch.
- That's the weirdest thing that I've--
- I might start a YouTube channel
that's just called Rhetching
which is (chuckles),
it's Rhett and stretching mixed together.
It's not throwing up.
'Cause it's spelled R-H-E-T-C-H-I-N-G,
Rhetching.
Rhett stretching 24/7.
It's a live stream.
And I'm listening to 24/7 lofi.
Inception.
- I think that's the weirdest thing.
I mean--
- Hold on but--
- You've seen me pick my nose,
I do that every day probably.
- My stretching, I was thinking
about this this morning,
I was having a conversation
with my pilates instructor
and it was,
I'm spending a lot more
time with my stretches
and not just my stretches but
the rolling on the ball thing.
I got a little lacrosse
ball and I get it into
all the different nooks
and crannies of my back
and all the places that there are knots.
And I have discovered that
especially getting ready
to go ski for a week I'm like,
a lot of times when I get ready
to transition in something,
I'm about to go on
vacation, my back gets tight
in anticipation of it,
it's a weird stress thing that happens.
You don't wanna be out there
having paid all this money
for this ski vacation
and then not be able--
- Seizing up.
- Not be able to ski.
So I been rolling my back out.
Upper, mid and lower with this ball.
- Well that's a weird--
- Every single morning.
- That's a weird thing to walk in on
'cause it just looks like
you're wallowing around
on the floor.
- And also I'm making noises
like (moans).
This is what Rhetching, the
Rhetching channel would be.
It would just be me laying
on the ground going (moans).
- You probably look like a
guy who's just suffered--
(groans)
Some sort of injury.
- Oh yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes. (chuckles)
Because it's good.
- You yes yes yes?
- Yes because
the pain is helping me.
The pain is so intense
but it's unraveling,
I don't know how the science
works, it's doing something
to the muscle knots, releasing
them, making me feel good.
Anyway I think this is
curing my life right now.
- I actually heard that
rolling out is now not,
it's not proven to be as
effective as active stretching.
- It's not proven to be as
effective for recovery, right?
Isn't that true?
- I don't know.
Next question.
- I'm rolling out
for a different reason,
I'm rolling out for knots.
I'm not rolling out for recovery.
- I like the way you work my--
- Lavish Lionel.
- Booty knot.
- Lavish Lionel asks,
I was recently asked: when you die,
if you were offered to
view a top five list
of some moments in your life,
which list would you choose?
Personally I'm learning
towards the top five times
I was closest to death.
Do you say towards or toward?
When you write.
- Towards.
- That is incorrect for--
- I don't write it.
I don't write it, I just say it.
- Well what I realized was happening,
I was looking at our
editor who had gone through
the Google docs where we wrote our novel
and all the towards had
been changed to toward
because--
- A lot of that.
- Towards is the U.K.
- Really?
- That's what I say, I always add the S
but technically the U.S.,
which I don't know why we got
so much beef about
little things like that.
Y'all don't have an S?
- And it's right, it's right
here, but it's wrong for there.
- And there's another weird word.
Oh, vise-like, okay.
Vise-like grip.
Okay, vise-like grip is
a word, it's a phrase.
- Vise dash like?
- That is in the--
- Space.
- The Lost Causes of Bleak Creek.
So how would you spell vise-like?
- Well with a dash, vise dash like.
- How would you spell vise?
- Oh.
V-I-C-E.
- Wrong!
- Yeah.
- It's V-I-S-E in America.
A vice in America with a
C is like a moral vice,
it's like part of you that's compromised.
- Oh but a tool.
- But a tool in America--
- Is with an S?
- Is with an S
and in the U.K. it's with a C both ways.
What is the world coming to?
Why do we have so many disagreements?
Why can't we just make a decision--
- We have enough for that just to be,
I mean you gotta keep standards
or the language is just
gonna fall into chaos.
But let's get to this question.
When you die you are offered
to view a top five list.
Man, I think that would be...
That would be frustrating
to only see five moments.
That's a short list.
- That's your complaint?
- I mean I would be grateful
for seeing anything I guess.
- Well which five would you choose?
- Like oh I'm still able
to see, I'm not nothing.
There is an afterlife, so check.
That's a good start, you know.
- But what would you--
- Oh and now I get to see
five things, I wanna see the
happiest moments of my life.
- But what if it's all
downhill from there?
- But then that might make you sad.
I actually think his answer's pretty,
Lavish Lionel had a pretty good answer.
I wanna see the top five
times I was closest to death.
- Well I would wanna see the ones I was,
my answer was closest to
death that I did not realize.
- Oh yeah, that's what
I thought was implied
and I think he has the best answer 'cause,
sorry for taking it, Lavish,
but hey props to you.
'Cause then you're really
grateful, it's like man,
I could have gone five other times.
- Yeah.
- Turns out I had six lives like a cat.
- And the thing is--
- Well like a
short-changed cat.
- And what kinds of things would those be?
It wouldn't be the most
obvious things like,
you think it would be things like,
well there was this one time
that you were almost hit
by a rig, it would be something
like there was this one time
where this virus that would
have gone into your brain
and started eating away at it.
- You washed your hands.
- You washed your hands
at exactly the right time.
- You blew your nose.
- You sneezed and if
you hadn't have sneezed,
you would be dead.
- Oh wow.
- It would be something like that,
or there was a moment in
which some little platelet
inside one of your veins
could have gotten stuck
and caused a stroke, I don't
know what causes a stroke.
- But it just skated by.
- Yeah.
And it would be like--
- That clot went
the wrong direction.
- It'd be the most boring
video in history, it'd be like,
you're just watching a vein.
What am I seeing here,
what am I seeing here?
Oh the platelet went the other
way, you would have died.
Closest to death.
- But I would still be very
grateful to not have died sooner
whereas where my initial
answer of the happiest moments,
that would probably just make
me so sentimental and sad.
But what you said reminded
me of the other night,
it's like you had 30 minutes
before it was bedtime,
I was like, we could watch
one episode of a sitcom
but I'm just gonna throw on YouTube
and see what's going on.
And there was this trending video
that was sports casters
getting upset part two
and I'm like, this is
trending, so it was new
and fresh, probably hadn't
seen it and I like--
- You watched this as a family?
- News but this was me,
Lincoln, Lando and Britton.
And I started watching
that one and it sucked
and then Britton was like, you
know what you should put on.
Close Calls from FailArmy.
- Oh gosh this is great.
- And then I'm like this
sounds like a good idea.
Well it wasn't a good idea because--
- Probably make you stressed out.
- You're sitting there and it's just like
a lot of traffic footage of okay,
here's just an intersection--
- In Russia.
- And all of a sudden
you see this motorcycle
instead of stopping, he didn't know how
to use the motorcycle and he
flips over the handlebars--
- And then he just walked away.
- And as he flips over and
tumbles into the intersection,
a car barrels through there
and just misses running over the guy.
- Close call huh?
- It was a close call yeah.
I mean the good news is
you know everybody makes it
'cause it's a close call,
it's not like morbid,
shouldn't actually be on YouTube
and can't stay up there--
- 'Cause that feels like it
would be rewarding to watch.
- Well the cumulative
effect of seeing a guy
in a cowboy hat with his
daughter, lookin' this,
where's the train, where's the train
and you can look past the guy
and see the train is coming
and you're like--
- What?
- You're standing--
- Coming the wrong way.
- On the rail, you're standing halfway
and at the last second he
turned 'cause he heard it
and got out of the way
but it was a close call.
- Very close call.
- I mean that was disconcerting man.
And all types of these things.
It just made me think ever since then,
if I'm walking on a sidewalk, I'm like,
what if I trip?
You've seen the videos of,
there were these two girls
walking down the street
on the sidewalk and the one girl just like
hip checked her friend just to be cute.
And the girl falls out
into the street and like,
a big frickin' bus comes by
and just barely misses
running over her noggin.
- Close call!
- It was a close call.
Miraculously timed and
miraculously caught on camera.
- Miraculously caught.
- Yeah man.
I was like I gotta turn this off.
They weren't censored either
so sometimes with a close call,
there's lots of colorful
language that's used.
So watch out for that.
- Do you have a rec for later?
'Cause you made me think of a rec based on
what you just said watching
something with your family.
- Yeah, save your rec.
Well if it's related
to this, just give it.
- I don't, my rec's not--
- I have a rec.
- My rec's not worthy of the final rec.
- Yeah, give it now.
This is a pre Recs in Effect.
- Goldbergs.
As a family--
- The television show?
- The television show which incidentally,
our own Shayne Topp is
a guest star, regular,
something, whatever you would say.
- Smosh Shayne, yeah.
- Yeah.
I've only watched--
- I was in a Thai restaurant
last night and they were playing Goldbergs
and it old Christy, I was
like, see that guy right there,
that's Shayne, he's in Smosh.
- I think that it's just
a good, it takes place,
you know the premise, it
takes place in the 80s.
But it's just a family
being a family and--
- I thought it was the 90s actually.
- It's the 80s actually, it's the 80s.
Maybe in some season it goes,
I don't know how many seasons--
- It'll get there.
- But it may be in the 90s but you know--
- Are you recommending the
show or something else?
- I'm recommending the show.
- Okay.
- I'm recommending the
show to watch as a family
because we sat there as a
family and realized how like
all these, every member of the
family is like a caricature
of a mom and a dad but it's
also based on this dude's life,
the creator of the show.
Adam
Goldberg.
- Goldberg.
(chuckling)
Okay.
- But anyway,
it was just like, I see how
I fall into the dad trope
and mom falls in the mom trope,
kids fall into the kids trope.
Anyway, it's a rec.
- What about near-death
experiences made you think of that?
- You said you sat down
and we have half an hour
to watch a sitcom as a family.
- Oh, oh.
- So I was gonna say that
if you're in the mood
for a half hour sitcom,
Goldbergs is a rec.
Let's ask another question though.
Taco picasso, HighlyEducxted
with an X asks,
how do you cheer yourself
up when you're feeling sad?
#EarBiscuits.
- The first thing I think of is music.
Music can help snap me out so I can go
with some bangers.
Gimme that banger playlist.
- Give me an example.
Miley Cyrus Party in the USA?
- Yeah Rhett, that's it.
- Hey, listen to that song
and tell me it's not catchy.
- It is a happy, happy song.
That song will make you happy.
I do not recommend the
song Happy 'cause it's--
- It's too on the nose.
- Played out.
It's played out.
Party in the USA's a bit tired
but it probably always works.
- Yeah it's not a rec,
I'm not making a rec, man.
Just making a ref, a reference.
- The thing that I do when
I'm feeling sad lately is--
- You been feeling sad lately?
- Actually yeah.
Well no.
There are times when
I feel sad in general.
I don't think more so lately
but when I said lately
I meant lately I'm trying to not say,
oh I feel sad, I'm going
to play Party in the USA,
but instead, just leaning into
it and saying you know what--
- Let's get sadder.
- If you feel a little sad,
let's just go ahead and let's
experience the entire wave
of that emotion--
- Yeah.
- Instead of trying to fight it, so,
interestingly enough, yesterday morning,
coming into work,
Spotify will create, based
on what you've listened to,
and I'm sure all of the
streaming services do it,
they'll create this
automated playlist for you.
- The AI, man, yeah.
- And I've been listening
to some more Merle lately,
gettin' back into Merle.
Well, there's a sad part to that too.
The other night I was listening to,
and I texted you about this,
I was listening to Ben Haggard,
Merle Haggard's youngest son
who we know and who got
us into his concerts
who basically enabled us to meet Merle
before he passed away a
little over a year ago
I guess it's been, maybe longer now.
- It's been two years.
- Yeah.
And I hadn't realized even
though you told me this
that he does some covers on his Instagram,
I guess that's another rec.
Follow Ben Haggard on Instagram.
Tell him that we sent you.
Rhett and Link sent me,
big fan, or whatever.
He does covers of, he just
sits in his intimate space,
like his living room or something
with this one studio mic
and covers lots of stuff but Merle songs.
And I did not realize, Christy
said, "Hey listen to this,
"I saw it on Facebook,"
'cause your mom had posted it.
Your mom had posted a Ben
Haggard cover of a Merle song
and she's like commenting, he's
friends with Rhett and Link,
and she's like commenting
on Facebook about it.
It was really cute.
And so Christy's telling me this
and she starts playing the
song and I'm just listening
to it and I was like, well this is Merle.
This is actually not Ben,
this is just a Merle song
that's being played.
But then she showed me the
video, I'm like no, this is Ben.
- I think he sounds just like Merle.
- He can sound, I mean we
know Merle Haggard so well
that, like all the
intracrisities, what's the word?
Intricaties.
- Intricitititties.
- Yeah, of his vocal delivery.
- Intricacies.
- Intricrisaty, I can't say it.
- Well intricate is the root word.
- Intricate cities.
- Intricatacy.
- Intricaties.
(Rhett chuckles)
Is that how you say it?
Intricaties.
Intricicaties, what is the word?
There's four people in this
room and no one else can say it.
- Intricaties.
- No one wants to try and say it.
- Whatever.
(Rhett laughs)
Intracicities, that's not right.
I cannot say--
- It's definitely not intricatitties.
That's the one thing that I know it's not.
- Intricatitties.
- Just the nuances.
- He's got intricatitties
you wouldn't believe it.
- Of his,
Merle's vocal delivery he
can nail to the point of,
here's what happened.
- Tell me what happened.
- Once I realized that it was Ben singing,
I just sat there and listened to it
and my eyes welled up with
tears and I started crying.
- Yeah, I get that.
- I could not, it was as if the ghost
of Merle had come back.
It was, and you know what,
I was just blown away
with the wave of emotion
and I think I realized
at that moment, I don't
think I ever fully mourned
the loss of Merle.
I didn't really sit down
and listen to the extent
that I should have, just
go through the mourning
of losing this guy, I was
telling Britton about it,
and he was like yeah when Tom Petty died,
I sat in my room and bawled my eyes out.
I cried myself to sleep
literally and he was like,
and it took a long time because
I was playing this one song
on YouTube and I had to press play every,
replay every time it stopped.
- And that was also related to the fact
that he had never seen
him live or something
or never met him or, 'cause Britton goes
to a bunch of concerts and so not having--
- He had never gotten to see him.
- Right.
- And like,
Coach Brandall, my
soccer coach in college,
I mean in high school,
I did not play soccer--
- College soccer, whoa.
News flash.
- He talked about when
what's his name from
the Grateful Dead died.
He was a Deadhead.
- Jerry Garcia?
- Jerry Garcia, he lit candles
and listened to the music
and just bawled his eyes out,
and I thought that's sweet
but I would never see myself
doing that, and I think--
- Now you get it.
- I was laying in bed
listening to Ben sing Merle
and like, I just started
crying and then I went
on his YouTube page and
started looking at the comments
and I felt validated that a
lot of people were commenting
that they were in tears
as a mourning exercise.
But anyway, all that's back story to,
I started listening to more
Merle because I had realized
that since his death,
I'd kinda been avoiding listening to him.
I think just not wanting to go there,
but I started listening
to him and then Spotify
started recommending Merle
and other country music people
as a certain playlist so I played that
on my way into work yesterday
morning and somehow,
it went from Merle to
some Travis Tritt song.
♪ It's a great day to be alive ♪
- Talking about growing a Fu Manchu,
it's kind of a hokey
song but I like Travis.
- Good.
- Shout out to Travis Tritt.
Happy song, and then
the next one it played,
I looked over--
- Intricacies.
- Intricacies, that's what
I was saying the whole time.
- We wanted some extra syllables in there.
- Jenna's afraid to say
it but she spelled it out
so that we could read it.
You say it.
- [Jenna] Intricacies.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, intricacies.
- The freakin' voice of
the AI in Independence Day.
- The orb.
- You can say
of intricacies.
- The voice of the orb.
- Intricacies.
So then I look at the next
song and I see it pops up,
Diamond Rio.
The song was One More Day.
- Oh.
- Do you remember this song?
♪ One more day ♪
♪ One more night ♪
- One more sunset, maybe I'd be satisfied.
- Yeah.
- But then again,
I know what it would do,
leave me wishing still
for one more day with you.
And I heard the first chord and I'm like,
I immediately reached for the skip.
I'm like, I am not doing this.
And I reached for it--
- Why?
- And just as my finger touched
the skip forward button,
'cause I wasn't gonna listen
to the Travis Tritt song again.
I was gonna go forward, I
was like you know what, no.
I'm gonna do this.
I'm like, in all that bumper
to bumper traffic in Glendale,
10 lane highway,
listening to it.
And it's basically about if
I had one wish granted to me,
I would wish to have one
more day with the person
whose loved one who had
apparently passed away.
And let me tell you.
(Rhett chuckles)
I bawled my eyes out.
I've never, this is, I've never done this.
- To Diamond Rio.
- Like yes,
I was crying.
- Oh wow.
- I was doing that ugly cry
where your face shrivels up--
- On the way to work?
- And I had my like,
I had to prop my elbow up
and put my hand over my face
so it looked like, I mean,
my face shriveled up and tears
rolling down, both eyes, man.
- I think there might be
something else you're accessing.
- Well I mean it made me think
of loved ones I've lost--
- Okay there you go.
- And I thought about it
specifically and so,
I listened to the whole
song and cried like a baby.
- Well ironically--
- And I didn't even wipe the tears away.
It was, you know what, let 'em fall.
- Ironically and fittingly,
I feel like there's two sides
of this coin, there's the leaning into it.
- Yeah.
- And then there's
the coming out of it and I
think that I've got something
for coming out of it.
- Okay great.
- You know a little bit about
this so one thing I'll say,
I think the first thing
I thought when I looked
at this question was,
I think that I, and
again, I talk about this,
I feel like I'm talking about
the fact that I go to therapy
every single podcast at this point
so sorry if that's annoying to you,
but I think traditionally my
answer to this would be like,
hmm, sad.
What is that? (chuckles)
You know what I'm saying,
because I know that I do get sad
but I tend to be so in my head--
- Right.
- That I think that,
I transmute my emotion of
sadness into other things
like anger probably or yelling
at the kids or something
because I don't process
and actually like you said,
lean into the sadness
and let it run its course
because I do think that sadness is a part
of a human condition and something
that we should not run from.
But assuming that you
let it run its course,
music I think is a way
to bring you out of it.
Now, I wanna talk to you
about a guy named Dr. Fun.
(both chuckle)
And there's probably a rapper
out there named Dr. Fun
and other people named Dr. Fun
so you may not get this guy
if you just Google Dr. Fun,
so our good friends Lance and
Lacey who, of Beard and Lady.
If you're a real Mythical Beast,
you know about Lance and
Lacey and Beard and Lady.
They make the lip balm
and beard oil and pomade.
Great friends back in North Carolina and
they're just both crazy
in the best possible way.
Lance and Lacey are just,
they're into interesting stuff
and they'll just start telling you
about something that happened
and there was somebody they know
and it's gonna be interesting.
- They're enthusiastically
open and it's not,
it's always refreshing to have
those people in your life.
- Yeah, and Lance will just
text me out of the blue.
He texted me recently and he said,
"I think that you're now
ready for Dr. Fun." (laughs)
Just like okay.
And then he just sends me--
- He's been sitting on
a Dr. Fun for awhile.
- He sends me a Facebook
video of this guy,
his name is Tim McGinnis.
That's M-C-G-I-N-N-I-S.
AKA Dr. Fun.
Now Lance knows this guy--
- Now when you say
AKA Dr. Fun I just wanna clarify that
his YouTube channel is
Tim McGinnis, AKA Dr. Fun.
All of that.
- Yes, that's it.
And this guy, Lance knew
him, Lance lived out here
in California for awhile,
before we ever did.
In fact when we met him in North Carolina,
he was moving back from
Pasadena and he knew this guy
in Pasadena, I don't
know exactly how they got
to know each other but
he said, "I knew this guy
"when I lived in California
"and he's just this super enthusiastic guy
"who makes all this original
music that is designed
"to focus your mood in
the right direction."
And--
- But you--
- He said, "And one time he
recorded my mouth trumpet
"and incorporated it into a song."
Just to give you an idea the
kinda guy that Dr. Fun is,
he knows that you can do the mouth trumpet
and Lance can do a mean mouth trumpet.
- I can do a mean mouth trumpet.
- Yeah.
- I wanna,
me and Lance should get into--
- You could be in a
Dr. Fun song.
- Mouth trumpet off.
- So anyway, so what Dr. Fun, Dr. Fun--
- Now it sounds like
you're saying two things
which I don't think are
true and that's one,
that he is like some sort
of therapist that two,
is residing in Pasadena, California.
- No no at this point, Dr.
Fun, Dr. Fun met a lady
and they--
- Mrs. Fun?
- They moved to Cabo San Lucas where,
you know, we've been down to Cabo.
In fact, speaking of
watermelons on shirts.
- Yeah.
- I see what you're doing there.
- A Mythical Beast gave
me this shirt on tour.
Might have given it to
you but it's too small.
- They moved to Cabo and I
don't know what he does besides,
he has this thing on
Facebook that he calls
The Dr. Fun Institute
For Intentional Thought Transformation.
(chuckles)
And as far as I can tell,
one of the main tenants
of The Institute For Intentional
Thought Transformation
is to sing these songs that
are almost like mantras
to get you in the right mood.
And listen, he'll go on
the rooftop of his home
in Cabo San Lucas and just,
this is an 18 minute video
and he's just going through,
he's just singing these songs,
making them up on the
spot or accessing them
from his library.
I don't know anything else about Dr. Fun.
- What do you mean his library?
Like his brain library.
- His brain library.
- So before you play it,
I just wanna clarify that
this is just a dude with,
he looks like he could be ex-military.
He's got close cropped hair.
He's wearing a black
t-shirt, probably shorts,
probably bare foot.
He's not in a clinical environment.
He's filming himself
on an iPhone vertically
in vlog format and it's
very extemporaneous.
- And let me just tell you--
- It's not planned.
- That these songs have been in my head
and I have found myself when
my, I'm not kidding you,
when I start thinking things or whatever,
I'm like I feel a little bit down,
a Dr. Fun song comes into my mind
and I just start singing
it and it does the trick.
- You using his system?
♪ Appreciation is my super power ♪
♪ Appreciation got me feeling high ♪
♪ Appreciation gives me wings to fly ♪
♪ One more time ♪
- Okay so he said one more time and then--
- He had already said one more time.
- So I'm just gonna go to--
- How many times does
he say one more time?
- He'll look off into the distance
and then another one will come out.
- [Dr. Fun] Look at
these aloes, it's true.
- He finds joy in all
the things around him.
Here's another one.
♪ Focus focus focus ♪
♪ On feeling good right now ♪
♪ I find the best feeling thought
for feeling good right now ♪
♪ One more time ♪
(Rhett laughs excitedly)
- One more time.
- I find the best feeling
thought for--
- Feeling good right now.
- I focus focus focus on
feeling good right now.
- [Rhett] Here's more.
♪ Breathe, relax ♪
♪ And let the magic happen ♪
♪ It's swirlin' all around you ♪
♪ Just relax and let it flow ♪
♪ I said ♪
- That one didn't rhyme
and it didn't need to.
- And I'm just gonna go--
♪ It's swirlin' all around you ♪
♪ Just relax and let it flow ♪
- I'm just going to a
random spot, 18 minutes.
He does this like every other day.
- [Dr. Fun] Ready?
♪ There's no need to wait or hesitate ♪
- Got a drum.
♪ I'm gonna feel good right now ♪
♪ There's no need to wait or hesitate ♪
♪ You know I'm gonna feel good right now ♪
♪ You know I'm feeling pretty
God darn good right now ♪
(Rhett laughs)
- Woo!
- I mean--
- And how many views does this have?
- 11.
- 11 views, guys.
- I think it's about to have more.
- 11 views.
- That's my theory.
- Dr. Fun is giving
you the musical mantras
that you need on the back side of sadness.
- There's another song where he's like,
he's walking down the
streets in Cabo San Lucas
and he's doing this
head thing and he's like
♪ Shift, shift, shift my
perspective 'til I'm feeling good ♪
♪ I'm gonna shift, shift,
shift my perspective ♪
♪ 'Til I'm feeling good ♪
And then I find myself singing this song.
I'm gonna shift, shift,
shift my perspective
'til I'm feeling good.
- I bet it works.
- It does work, it's magic!
Dr. Fun is magic because
there's just, you know,
it's scientifically
proven that just smiling
makes you feel better, right?
Just the act of smiling,
even if it's a forced smile,
your body begins to do
the things emotionally
that is associated with a smile.
And Dr. Fun has got this institute, man.
I mean again it's The Dr. Fun Institute
For Intentional Thought Transformation.
He's intentional about his
thought transformation.
He uses these songs.
- What is the institute?
- It's him, he is an institution, man.
(both laugh)
- Wow, but you're telling
me that Lance knew this guy
in person, like in the flesh in Pasadena
and mouth trumpeted with him?
- First of all, you know Lance and Lacey.
They meet in person like
Dr. Fun, they're on it.
You know what I'm saying,
there's a lot of people
who might be like, this guy,
this dude's a little nuts, man.
- Keep a distance.
- He's movin' to Cabo, he's
singin' songs all the time.
But Lance and Lacey understand that
this guy figured something out.
Not only is he just
interesting and entertaining,
but there's something going on there.
- He's manifesting inner
happiness through musical mantra.
- Yes.
And anyway--
- And occasionally a
mouth trumpet apparently.
- Yeah I think, I don't know, again,
I'm just scratching the
surface of the Dr. Fun world,
I don't know how far it goes.
- A lot of videos?
- Yeah, he's been making
videos for like seven years
on YouTube, he's got his Facebook deal.
- He's got a deal with Facebook?
- (chuckles) He's got a deal
with Mark Zuckerberg himself.
- Wow.
- He's got a Facebook page
where he does the same thing
and he seems like he's got his--
- Crazy.
- His audience which is not
super large but is what
he needs to keep going,
and anyway, Dr. Fun, there's a rec.
- Kristian Drake asks,
what did I see in the
sky yesterday morning?
Then posts a photo from the phone.
What you saw was three light sources.
Three sources of light, connect
the dots, form a triangle.
That's what you saw.
- So you don't think it was
anything suspicious or alien?
- Well we just don't
have a lot to go on here.
- It is just a still image for us.
If you're not watching this
podcast, you don't even see it.
So probably nothing, Kristian.
Christie Byers asks, what's
something that is popular
right now but in five in 10 years,
everyone will look back on
and be embarrassed about?
- Five years is not a long
time to be embarrassed,
so I'm thinking more 10
years, like a full decade.
Do you have something?
- I have something that's not a,
it's not like a fashion--
- That's good,
'cause you--
- Accessory.
- Immediately think fashion, I'm like,
I think my kids will be embarrassed
wearing sweat pants everywhere.
- Just like we were.
You look at that picture
of us at Pizza Inn--
- We're embarrassed--
- For my birthday party.
- [Link] Why you wearing sweat pants
for a birthday party?
- And not only did we have--
- Are you sick?
- It wasn't that we
(chuckles) had sweat pants on.
We had on a sweat suit
that didn't have a name,
it was just like, no logos.
- Turns out we were ahead of our time.
- It was like just a gray
sweat, you had a gray sweatshirt
and gray sweatpants on, matching.
And Brooks Lee had on, it
was all red or something.
And we didn't think he was
cool, it was just comfortable.
- Yeah it worked.
- Are you sick? (chuckles)
Yeah, I was thinking,
I honestly think that, you know how you go
in any society situation at this point,
any public place and everyone's
looking at their phone.
- Yeah.
- I choose to believe that it's a phase.
- I like this.
- I choose to believe that it is a phase
and I choose to believe that--
- I didn't know you had
faith in humanity like this though.
- I don't have faith in humanity but--
- Then how on earth do
you think we're gonna get
out of our phones.
- 'Cause I think that first of all,
we're gonna continue to learn all the,
first of all, speaking of
Dr. Fun and feeling happy
and shifting your perspective,
shifting your face down into your phone
and doing the thing that we
all do which is you go from
your favorite app to
your next favorite app
to your next favorite app
and then rinse and repeat
and you kinda just find yourself,
sometimes I just find myself
Instagram, Twitter, Reddit.
Whatever.
- Yeah just--
- And I'm just like
what, I'm like standing
at the bottom of my stairs in
my house just standing there
in the dark, just like
(mumbling nonsense).
And I know I'm not
alone, and it's just sad.
- What, someone's standing there watching?
- Yeah there's a ghost.
It's sad, it's unnecessary,
it's not good for your mind,
it's not good for your sleep patterns,
it's not good for your neck,
it's not good for your eyes.
And I think eventually--
- But by the way I do
think that when I die,
I wanna see a highlight
reel of just all the times
I just was standing in the
stupor looking at my phone.
I think that's your point.
- Yeah and I think that we're going to,
I think a lot of people are realizing,
kinda waking up to the fact
that this is all they do.
They stare at their hand,
their handheld device.
But first of all, I think that
some things are gonna change
like I mean, distant, not so
near future but you know--
- I think they'll be a--
- First of all, the interesting thing is,
you know how AirPods were really dorky
and now it's like a status symbol
and like all the kids want them.
It was like, oh looks like cigarette butts
coming out of your ear
but now it's like, no Dad,
I gotta get some AidPods.
The same thing will happen
with displays in glasses.
- Right.
- It's gonna happen.
It makes so much more sense.
There's gonna be a second
wave of Google Glass
or something like that
that doesn't make you
look like a dweeb and then
everybody's gonna have it.
And then there will be a period of time
where people are standing
there in the days
and they're not looking at anything
'cause they're looking in their fricking
display in their eyes but I just feel like
we're gonna get to a place where--
- A cultural renaissance of wellness.
- I think we have to, and you know me,
I'm all about the future, futurology,
the technology and the
fusion, the human...
I was gonna say human
animal hybrids. (chuckles)
- Oh gosh.
- The trans-humanism.
I think all that's coming but I think that
it can't come at the
expense of our own health
and I think that somebody,
somewhere along the line,
like our kids are gonna like wake up
at some point--
- I think if you're saying
that education, like,
there'll be education
for kids to protect them
and they'll be an infrastructure
of societal positive
pressure towards wellness.
- Not just wellness.
- I mean that's
a hopeful view.
I am hopeful.
- But that does happen.
What happens is we replace our vices.
V-I-C-E,
with other vices.
So they'll be something like
everybody's staring into their
phone and then we'll realize
we shouldn't do that,
it's just like, okay,
back when we were in growing up
it's like kids smoked all the time.
- Yeah.
- Now kids vape all the time
and they think, in the
same way that, not us,
but back in the 40s they
thought that smoking was okay
for you and now all these people are like,
vaping's not bad.
Vaping is bad for you.
It is bad for you and
they're discovering more
and more every day that it's bad for you.
You shouldn't be doing it.
It's not a safe alternative to cigarettes.
And then something else,
something else will replace it.
So I'm just thinking we'll
look back on this moment
in time in which we had these handheld,
this idea of a smartphone
is so new culturally.
10 years ago they were just
being introduced, right,
and it was just becoming a
part of everybody's life.
We're a decade into this experiment
and we're not doing well.
And I think that we're gonna,
it might take another 10 years
but I think that we're
gonna look back and be like,
man, in every picture everybody's
looking at their phones.
Not cool.
I hope.
- I like
leaving that hopeful
note as our last answer.
'Cause I got a rec to give.
- Okay, all right, I'm down.
- I thought that I would not give a
music-related recommendation
because I, you know,
you kinda told me I was only
giving music recommendations
and I'm like hey, you know what,
I got other things I can recommend.
Like that Diamond Rio One
More Day song, I mean,
if you wanna have a
meditative sad experience
and you can handle that mid 90s country.
- That's a big hurdle for a lot
of people to overcome though.
- You might deem it schmaltzy.
That's not my Recs in Effect.
♪ Check baby check baby,
one two three four ♪
I'm gonna give you a
thread on Reddit to follow.
- Oh, nice.
- Holla.
From puppy to dog.
- Oh, yes.
- You seen this?
- No, but I can imagine what it is.
- You can imagine what it is.
- Side by side, right?
- You got side by side photos.
Lots of times recreating the photo
of when you got your puppy.
Now you got a big dog sitting in your lap.
- And the bigger the breed,
the better the change.
- Yeah, man.
And it's...
I don't know, there's this,
it's obviously very cute,
it's very tender.
But there is a tinge of
sadness associated with it
because it captures the passage of time
and how it's accelerated
in the life of a dog.
You know, as much as I love Jade,
I can't separate my love from Jade with
the knowledge that she's gonna pass.
Much more likely before I will.
I hope so, I hope she dies before me.
- Yeah.
- I mean that's a weird thing to say.
- But you should, you should hope that.
- Jade, I hope you die before me.
- It seems like a sad thing to say.
It seems mean almost but--
- So I'm making a
recommendation that if you want,
I mean there's a tinge of
sadness but there's so much cute
and happiness involved that it's worth it.
- The funny thing is--
- From puppy to dog.
- The funny thing is is
that Jade would not be
a very exciting puppy to
dog because she looks like
the day that you adopted her.
- She's a lot smaller, you know what,
I'll try to find in post a puppy to dog.
I'll try to do that on my,
shout out on my Instagram.
- She was like a third of that size?
- LinkLamont.
She was really little, yeah.
- She was almost like
hand-sized, wasn't she?
- Yeah.
I mean, at least in this one picture.
The first picture we, I don't know if I,
I'll have to see if I
can find a good picture
that I'm in 'cause you need
to have a sense of scale.
The ones I'm thinking of
don't have a sense of scale,
it's just her.
- Yeah I remember--
- We'll see.
- We took Barbara to a dog
park and she was tripping
over the grass, I do remember that.
She was that little.
So let's both try to recreate.
Let's recreate a puppy to dog moment
and then we were gonna
add it to the thread
or we just gonna add it to
the world of Mythicality?
- Well my account is like a--
- You ever posted anything to Reddit?
- My account's a secret
account so I haven't created
like a, I don't know, I
didn't know what Reddit was
and I didn't know how I
was gonna interact with it
so I just made up an account on the spot.
So I haven't, it's not public
and it's not findable I don't think.
And if you did find it,
I don't think you'd--
- You'd be uninterested.
Okay, that's another Ear Biscuit.
Again, we don't always do the AMAs.
This is something that we've
done every couple months or so.
Let us know what you think
about the AMA format.
I have fun, I feel like we go down a lot
of different paths, talk about
a lot of different things.
- Yeah.
- Never know what
you're gonna get.
- Yeah.
- I'd like to do more but
only if you guys want more.
So let us know what you
think about the AMA format.
#EarBiscuits.
We do search that, we search it up.
- Yeah we do.
- We search it down.
- All right thanks for
hanging out with us.
Thanks for telling
people about Ear Biscuits
and recommending this podcast as well
as reviewing it on iTunes.
Apparently that's still a thing.
Review it up.
- Make some stars.
- We'll talk at you next week
on the back side of our vacations.
- Oh yeah.
- [Link] To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)